hey bro hey excuse me I called you
kajillion times why don't you call me
back
oh I'm so sorry I was too busy not
wanting to talk to you
Oh Jerry what are you doing Leslie asked
me to post these around the neighborhood
I'll do it
really yeah you want some help with that
we just stopped in listen to me
no fine I don't talk to you anyways
reverse psychiatry fine what I like you
in a romantic OL kind of way
you do yes do you like me yes
so then perhaps shall we go out this
evening no mm-hmm I don't think we
should see each other damn it because
you're 21 and I'm 29 no I don't care
about that it's because whenever I see
you talk to Anne or talk about Anne I
feel like you still have feelings for
her
what no I don't but I don't really I
don't
well I think you do so that's a problem
for me
Hey I just heard are you okay yeah oh my
god listen what I said this afternoon
was stupid
okay I totally want to go out with you
good I want to be with you
that was nice yeah yeah here's just one
thing real quick I want to be totally
honestly because I like you so much for
a few minutes ago me and Ann did kiss
what
but here's none of oh it was crazy she
kissed me okay I think wait where are
you going
dude don't even think about kissing me
you're trying to lure this young lady in
your van yeah well she's being really
difficult about it and it's actually not
my van I stole it from a friend of mine
I technically shouldn't be even driving
because my license is crazy expired
that's Dwyer D w-why II are dude come on
I gotta get out of here
Natalie tell this guy you know me do you
fish April no fish are close let me give
you a piece of fishing advice instead I
don't when you have a fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about
maybe not maybe you really do hate Andy
maybe moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know
[Music]
well yeah how did it go today was super
fun it was yeah do you have a list for
tomorrow you want to do this again
tomorrow yes I do
I mean it's a deal right I got a do for
a whole month and then you're not gonna
move to Indianapolis better be the only
person in kiss today yeah I'm I'm
positive that you are this is awesomely
perfect burly just moved in with his
rich girlfriend and we need help with
the rent we have a couple house rolls oh
yeah sure of course you can't use the
front door you have to climb in through
the back window no personal phone
conversations if you ever speak to me in
Spanish please use the formal usted and
no electricity after 6:00 p.m.
okay you can use as much free
electricity as you want it's free game a
couple new rules if you ever watch a sad
movie you have to wear mascara so you
can see whether or not you've been
crying there's no noise a lot of Mondays
and no TV after breakfast its head to
toe
no we leave the TV on all day long some
burglars think that we're home we're not
which is my idea that I'm trying to
patent so you want to move in tonight
yeah sure that'd be great
oh my god work
for morning roomie how'd you sleep well
there were no bedbugs also no bed I'm
gonna go buy a bed fork I'm sorry are
you eating turkey chili off of a frisbee
or a cute right no do you know what cute
means what have you got against turkey
chili for breakfast what have you guys
got against washing dishes we don't have
any dishes okay
burly took them all when he left now I
bet you feel like a jerk okay I might
need to not stay here anymore no sorry
dude we already spent your money on a
new Xbox 360 and more frisbees to eat
off of you got a stay oh good okay all
right here's the deal
we're gonna clean this place up okay and
then I'm going to teach you how to be
adults cool we'll get to be adults good
golly thanks mister for ah hate talking
to people about things this is a
nightmare
Oh grouchy huh we have to support Tom
think about it as role-playing that
makes it sexy that could be fun okay can
I use a weird voice and try to freak
people out yes okay and uh next time you
see me I'll be a stranger
hello strange person who I have never
met before who are you
I'm Janet snake-hole I'm a very rich
widow with a terrible secret who are you
Bert Macklin FBI was the best damn age
they had until I was framed for a crime
I didn't commit
stealing the president's rubies now I
work alone lovely to meet you I got to
admit I thought your costume would maybe
be a little bit [ __ ] err nice
do you think I haven't been around the
world been everywhere darling I'm a very
wealthy woman my husband kept me in the
finest clothes from Bergdorf Goodman's
freeze FBI kill anybody and I didn't
burn down the middle either my sister no
but now she beneath my walls nothing to
see here
turns music down buzzer Bhupathi [ __ ] I
feel phenomenal yeah you come in to make
a nothing up with that I did then we got
doctor says it's probably not serious
but it might be Oh Kyle please start
talking why isn't it Bert Macklin what
are you doing here
and who is this sorry Charlie I'm Janet
snake-hole I demand answers
now please I love you no offense but
Bert Macklin died last night after the
10th shot of snakejuice okay
sorry miss snake hole you think I'd let
you get away that easily
Bert Macklin may be dead but I'm his
brother Kip Hackman why wouldn't you
have his same last name shut up Kyle I
know you boosted those paintings maybe
it was me but I'll never tell you where
they are and you'll never have my body
either there are no TVs anywhere this
place is lamer than outside I'm chillin
what is that Jim
[Laughter]
found you and I had to fight a squirrel
told you I was gonna take you camping
didn't I yeah well I'm taking you
camping look at this this is one I had
set up at the other campsite except for
it was way nicer there but this'll do
I've got some champagne and I had a
drink most of it to survive so I'm kind
of buzzed right now I'm just glad you're
here
we got now
you